i think my smartest business decision
has been
going for it and not being like having
no fear
and just even if they failed and even if
it hasn't turned out the way that i
wanted to i've learned so much from it
so my advice would be go for it
kim kardashian is officially a
billionaire
yeah you heard me billion with a b
i love that on tuesday forbes reported
that the keeping up with the kardashians
star
is worth one billion dollars amid the
success of kim's company's kkw beauty
and skims according to the outlet which
notes that the 40 year old
also cashes in for her reality show
endorsement deals and other investments
kim's net worth increased in 2020 after
she sold
20 of kkw beauty to cody for
200 million dollars it was
a whirlwind then there's kim's little
sister kylie jenner
who previously feuded with forbes over
her billionaire status
when they published a may 2020 article
alleging kylie lied about her finances
a claim she strongly denies the makeup
mogul made a
killing when she sold 51 of kylie
cosmetics
to beauty conglomerate cody 2. to me
self-made is when you know everyone has
a team
i don't care who you are how you you
know but when you don't get it
from someone else that's self-made so
it's not like that was handed to her she
figured that all out
i mean we all have in june 2020 kim's
now estranged husband kanye west took to
social media to praise kim after she
made the deal with cody
tweeting quote i am so proud of my
beautiful wife kim kardashian west for
officially becoming a billionaire
you've weathered the craziest storms and
now god is shining on you
and our family you know he might say
things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart
kanye was also previously named a
billionaire by forbes in
april 2020. last month bloomberg
reported that the 43 year old rapper's
yeezy brand is now valued between 3.2
and 4.7 billion dollars
shooting the grammy winner's total worth
to an estimated
6.6 billion dollars
and when it caught up with kim in 2017
she said she hopes that her four kiddos
that she shares with kanye
will be inspired by their work ethics
i think our kids will see you know kanye
and i work really hard and i hope that's
motivating for them
and just to find their own path